تحمل على متنها ايضا اعضاء من السلك
الدبلوماسي ايضا سوف نتعرف عليها او سوف
نتعرف عليهم عند دخولنا قليلا
ما زلنا ان نقوم ايضا بس ننتظر اعطاء
ننتظر
اعطائنا التوجيه النهائي ننتظر نعم اعطانا
التوجيه النهائي بالدخول ويتقدم المصور
قليلا اذا نحن نقوم بالصعود الان على متن
هذه السفينه وايضا ناخذ جوله داخل سفينه
جلاله
الملك الطائف التي تصل في هذه اللحظات
هؤلاء هم طاقم السفينه
الذين اتموا هذه المرحله واتم عمليه
الاجلاء ونشاهد الاعداد الكبيره ايضا من
الجنسيات او المواطنين من جنسيات مختلفه
اسعد الله مساءكم الحمد لله على السلامه
شكرا لكم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بغياره الملك محمد بن سلمان عهده دعنا
نتحدث في البدايه من اين انتم من اي مدينه
ودعنا نتحدث عن الاحداث التي شاهدتموه
والله الاحداث انا انا سوداني هولندي احمد
الجنسيه الهولنديه الهولندي نعم
دبلوماسي او فقط ضابط شرطه
الاحداث الحاضره في السودان طبعا الشعب
السوداني ما عنده فيها اي نوع ولا جمله زي
ما بيقولوا
والاحداث لغات هي مستمره
واتينا الى بورسودان وصلنا بعد الاخوان
التواصلك كيف بدات
تواصل لا نجدان
تنسيق مع سفارتك ما في دوله وقفت مع
السودان غير المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وربع صراحه
ما في هذه المعلومه ما الذي شهدته شايف
انا انا شايف انا شفت
من
الخرطوم يعني في السعوديين بيجوا بيزعلوا
الناس دارين حاجه بعد لغايه ما اتوا الى
بورسودان كل جنسيه معينه ام الجنسيه لا اي
جهه هي قريبه 58 جنسيه
في هذه الصخره نعم اوصف 28 جنسيه ما عندهم
فرق بين انه ده سوداني ده اجنبي واحد هم
جايين لي خدمه الذين اتوا الى مدينه
مشرفه
نشكرهم على هذه الوقفه المشرفه تعرفت على
بعض الجنسيات التي في اندونيسيا امريكان
في انجليز سودانيين وجنسيات مختلفه
يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا لك اذا هذا حديث احد
الاخوه الذي وهو علمتنا هذه السفينه ويحمل
الجنسيه الهولنديه والذي تحدث هناك اكثر
من 28 جنسيه ولو نقترب قليلا ايضا نشاهد
على الواصلين من جنسيات مختلفه وايضا كبار
وصغار ايضا نشاهد لو ندخل قليلا ونشاهد
ايضا بعض الجنسيات التي وصلت لربما ان
كانت اغلب الجنسيات التي نشاهدها الان هي
جنسيات
اجنبيه وليست عربيه لم نرصد حتى الان اي
الجنسيه العربيه لعلنا نشاهد احد الاشخاص
في الزاويه الاخرى
او عفوا
غير الجنسيه السودانيه او يعني تقريبا لا
يوجد الجنسيات الاجنبيه
والحمد لله على سلامتكم
من وين يا حبيبي من تركيا نحنا من تركيا
نعم كيف تمت عمليه اجراءك كيف بدات
وكيف تم تنسيقك او تنسيق مع مين بالضبط
بالتفصيل نعم نحن من الناس
البارجة معنا ناس البارجه التركيه هي انت
عمل في البارد لا انا عامل هناك عامل حر
عامل حر نعم انا معي عيالي نحن تسعه نفر
معانا صاحبنا استاذ هناك بجامعه خيريه
عشره نفر زائد 24 نفر تانيين برضو اتراك
فيه موجودين هنا التمينا معه وزاره
الخارجيه التركيه
كلنا اجتمعنا مع بعض ويكثر خيرهم اخواننا
السعوديين اجوا استضافونا اكرمونا
والحمد لله وصلنا لحد هنا
عمليه التنسيق هل كانت طويله كانت استجابه
العمليه الاجلاء سريعه ام كانت والله في
زحمه زي دي اكيد حتكون شويه في ضعف لانه
بيكون في ثقل الناس في خوف الناس جاي من
برا عشان تيجي تعمل لك الاجراءات في
الاجراءات شويه بسبب المشاكل الحاصله
الزحمه الزحمه يعني الزحمه احنا ما كنا
متوقعين الناس يكون في اجانب كميه اجانب
في السودان دائره تتخارج هل هناك ما زالت
اعداد كبيره شهدت فيه معزات كبيره كم
اعدادهم تقريبا والله في تقريبا يعني اقل
شيء من 200 الف نفر في بورسودان 200 الف
يريدون الخروج والهرب نعم نعم نعم هذه
مشاهد انت شاهد انا 200
نفر يمنيين لسه ما كانوا واصلين
اربع مئه اربع مئه واحد 400 استغفر الله
استغفر الله 400 واحد نعم 400 شخص باقي
الاتراك صادروه من الخرطوم لا ادي سبب في
الطياره تقريبا 18 28 بس عن طريق اديس
من السودان استطاعوا الخروج من السودان دي
السفريه تقريبا مده معون اربعه ايام لما
نوصلوا اسطنبولو لكن نحن مبارح الحمد لله
ركبنا والليله هنا الحمد لله بامني وامان
اكلين وشاربين يعني المويه دي براها نعمه
يكثر خيركم الله يجزيكم خير الحمد لله على
سلامتك يعطيك العافيه اذا من الجنسيه
التركيه ايضا
يتحدث انه خلال يوم من يوم امس حتى اليوم
استطاع الخروج بسلام وامان رفاقه
مضوا اربعه ايام عن طريق اديس ابابا
للخروج من اديس ابابا الى اسطنبول كما
تحدث وذلك عبر وذلك بسبب الاجراءات التي
تحدث بها ان هناك اجراءات صعبه واجراءات
معقده قليلا الان
الان قائد القوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه الفريق
الفريق ركن فهد الغفيلي وهو قائد القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه يقوم بالوصول في
هذه اللحظات
وايضا يقوم بالسلام على
ركاب
السفينه جلاله الملك الطائف
طبعا هذه المره المره الاولى التي يقوم
بزياره هو بالفعل كانت الايام الماضيه
يتابع وايضا الجهات الاخرى تتابع عمليه
الاجلاء وايضا هنا نشاهد وصوله في هذه
اللحظات ولعلنا ايضا نحاول ان نقوم باجراء
لقاء معه في هذه اللحظات ولكن في البدايه
هو يقوم بالسلام على
طاقم السفينه الذي في حقيقه الامر نستطيع
الذي نجح في اجلاء هؤلاء الاشخاص من
جنسيات مختلفه عديده وكذلك كما تحدثنا قبل
قليل عن الوضع الراهن لهم كيف هو حالهم
وكيف ايضا كانوا وكيف كان وضعهم عند
وصولهم الى هذه المنطقه
لنا سوف نعود قليلا من اجل ان نحصل على
اكثر قدر ممكن من اللقطات
هو مازال يقوم بالسلام على ضيوف
هناك كلمه سوف يلقيها
الحمد لله وصلت
بامانه ان شاء الله
والمملكه ترحب فيكم وهذا اللي عمل عمل شيء
واجب علينا
ودائما نقول انتم في مملكه انسانيه في
مملكه الرحمه
والاخوه والله يحييكم ونسال الله التوفيق
ان شاء الله لكم وان شاء الله احنا جاهزين
نسهل كل اجراءات ان شاء الله ووصولكم الى
دوركم بحول الله
كل واجب يعني واجب علينا والحمد لله هذه
توجيهات
قائد مسيرتنا
العهد وزير الدفاع جميع اجهزه الدوله
توجيه واضح وصريح نقدم ما نستطيع في سبيل
راحتكم ان شاء الله وفي سبيل ان شاء الله
توصلون الى المنطقه ابدا
قواتك القوات الجويه التي وقفت وقفه مشرفه
رواه البحريه
ضباط على جنود على عساكر كانوا بيخدمونه
الشنط على اكتافهم الشرف الوطني بتاع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ليس بغريب على
مملكه الانسانيه واجب علينا والله يوفقكم
ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا
الثامنه اليوم التي تصل وهي جلاله الملك
الطائف كيف نتحدث عن استمرار عمليه الجلاء
من جنسيات متعدده من السودان الحمد لله
احنا توجيهات اسمه سيدي وزير الدفاع واضحه
نسخر جميع الامكانيات القوات البحريه في
سبيل جلاء الرعايه الرعايه احنا لا ننظر
لا جنس ولا عرق ولا جنسيا ننظر لجميع
الانسان احنا نتكلم بكل امانه وصراحه هذه
مملكه الانسانيه فانه ارحب وجميع ما نملك
من قدرات فهي مسخره لهم
شكرا ما عليك يعطيك العافيه شكرا اذا كان
حديث معالي قائد القوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه الفريق ركن فهد الغفيلي حول ان
هناك توجيه واضح من وزير
توجيه واضح لخدمه جميع الجنسيات وجميع
الجنسيات قدر المستطاع ووصولهم الى
السعوديه بسلام وامان لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات